he's the former NFL quarterback he's
Ryan Leaf back here in the man cave this
your first visit to this man cave yes it
is it's it's special how would you
describe this for somebody who is
listening on radio this man cave if you
if you enjoy sports in any degree it is
heaven that's that's a good way to but
they walked me through this way so I got
to see his part then they brought me out
the back end where I walked onto the
football field first ya saw the little
weight room yeah and in the basketball
court yeah if I had that in my house
yeah I would I would do nothing but
shoot hoops all day what kind of
basketball player were you in high
school
I was I was decent I mean it was Montana
which doesn't have the greatest
basketball but there were some really
good players during that span that were
from some small towns and I played a lot
of basketball with them that's why was
my favorite sport if I could have played
basketball I would I just wasn't of
course good enough to do it I got an
opportunity to walk on as a freshman in
Washington State and of course coach
price just was like you know you could
you could make a living out of this
football thing if we really put effort
into it you know and he convinced me but
that was part of the recruiting process
right when I went and did my recruiting
it was it was viable that I got chance
to play basketball as well but we've
talked about this I I always wondered if
he truly loved football because I didn't
get the feeling that it was the most
important thing to you where is and
you're always compared to Peyton Manning
for Peyton it was his life right like he
loved it I didn't think you loved
football I think I loved what came with
it okay okay yeah but for the longest
time before it became something bigger
than me I loved it I mean I would spend
hours in the film room with coach price
I would be on the football field I love
to practice I just hated going into work
because of what the the constant
criticism the back-and-forth with my
teammates and I really didn't think that
money was gonna change me but when I got
all that money I just was like I got
everything I need and I want to do this
other cool stuff I you know when was it
like that first check that you got
signing bonus well I was angry as hell
because so many taxes were taken out of
it so I like called my dad and I said I
was like almost crying for how much
money was taken out in taxes and he's
like he made it very
clear to me he said son the more money
that's coming out in taxes means the
more money you're getting paid just keep
keep that in perspective so but yeah
that was really much was that that well
they split it up it was eleven point two
five million dollars Wow so you got a
check for a lemma no they split it into
three things so the first one was like
you poor thing how did you get by in
like three point four million point
eight what did you do that that that
next day you got the first check for
almost four million dollars well I was
my dad set me up with a proper financial
adviser and it it went there I mean I I
started out the right way you didn't do
anything stupid originally no I I didn't
it's crazy right you're in college and
you can't afford anything and every and
no one will get anything for you but
then when you're in the pros and you can
buy anything you want everybody wants to
give you some so what they gave me like
a Toyota 4runner to drive around in so I
drove you know I didn't have I didn't go
on buy a car I think the biggest thing I
did my mom took me down we looked for
some furniture and I got like a big TV
like a large TV was the first purchase I
ever really made with met with that
money yeah how long did it take for that
money was gone um a long time it takes a
long time just to get rid of that money
I mean it's all gone now it that's all
that money's all gone now now I'm making
new money okay so that's that's
different but yes it that was the
hardest part even when I walked out in
prison the last thing I held on to was
the idea that I was broke for other
people I still wanted people to believe
that I had money that made me more
important that even if that was this
drug addict and felon and all of these
things being rich was still what made me
powerful and important but in your mind
you don't want to tell somebody you're
flat broke walking out of prison no but
I did I pretty much did on your show
like with it oh yeah you know I pretty
much came out and and with the help of a
bunch of people that have really
continued to build me back up they just
blatantly said hey you being transparent
and you being honest about everything
because people people already have
nailed this Ryan you're not fooling
anybody I don't think you were yeah no I
thought I was in the longest time
right I thought when I walked into a
room and I was a mess
and walked out I didn't think anybody
actually saw what was going on and so
yeah that was that was that whole that
the whole thing that I held on to the
last it was like this huge pride thing
that was the last thing that the last
domino to fall when it did it just
opened up an unbelievable life for me I
walked out of prison
I couldn't rub two pennies together I
wouldn't been able to go to treatment if
it weren't for the NFL and their
programs and that's where it started and
you have benefits through the NFL yeah
you played long enough yeah I'm a vested
I'm invested Ventures about three years
you get five years of health insurance
after you retire but the true benefits I
think are what the NFL Legends community
does which I'm a part of now and how we
help former players with the trust with
the NFLPA the biggest thing for me is
like the counseling benefits right they
they'll I go to counseling you know
fifty to two times a year once a week
and that's expensive but the NFL
we have benefits that pay for that for
the mental health side of things works
with couple counseling it works where
our prescription medication when we're
getting older the biggest thing for me
of course and the one that I want
changed is but I but I'm also thinking
knowing you and having been around you
and seeing you when you were somebody
some thing at least in our minds and
then you were at your lowest do you get
that cocky that confidence back that you
were kind of like where you were when
you were with the Chargers or you know
where you're the big man on campus there
because now you've got some notoriety
people are you know giving offering you
jobs and and you know now it feels like
you made it through there and is there
that risk of becoming the old Ryan Leaf
yes there is there's always that risk
because the Eagle was a huge part of you
know what took me down that path but
what I've done differently is that I've
become part of a program and I've
surrounded myself with different people
people who hold me accountable who I've
asked to hold me accountable and I think
that's the best word there is in the
English language because it's it's what
your part isn't all this and also I know
that none of this can be about me and
ever again like it can't be about me
even though I may be doing something
people stand up in claps sometimes if I
go speak at an event they're applauding
me it that really has nothing to do with
me it has to do with somebody in the
audience who may need that you did it a
few weeks or a few months ago where I
mean just you were transparent yeah and
there was somebody out there that heard
you and could feel the same type of way
and that's kind of what fuels me there's
a humility to it and you can't talk
about being humble it's just it's just
an understanding of who you are you know
who you are now regardless of what
anybody else says does or anything well
you you have to be humble you can't say
your home exactly no age and that's why
I didn't even tell the dance I was going
to make that announcement of what I was
going through health-wise because I
thought they might talk me out of it and
I had to just I had to say it and I
didn't know where I was going I knew I
was gonna get emotional but as my wife
said if you can help one person being
honest and letting them know because you
know I I wanted to hide it and then I
didn't know if I was hiding it and then
in your mind you're going not everybody
can see this the craziest and the best
thing about what has happened with my
relationship with you and the show is
exactly what you just said and what your
wife said is that when I've come on your
show people have reached out neither
asked for help or talked to me about how
it inspired them to change in a positive
way and you that's exactly what you
talked about one person it may be in one
person and it's continued dan I mean to
this day I still get direct messages in
my in my Twitter account or anything
else talking about we love your
appearances on Dan Patrick show I went
and sought out help after I heard I mean
that's what it's done for me
and that's why I I know you guys are
talking about that's why i call Fritzi
every time I'm in the area cuz I'm like
I know how far you can reach somebody
and when you did it the other day too
that just it just compounds that and it
enforces it for everybody else but I
also made it about me and my wife said
make sure you make sure you make it
about everybody else because you can
make it about yourself but use that as a
launching pad to make it about everybody
else and she was right I I'm saying hey
I'm not what I used to be and I'm making
some mistakes here maybe you don't know
it but I know it and I want a
want to laugh with you I don't want you
to laugh at me and then she said no it's
about you know talking to somebody being
honest with somebody being willing to be
transparent and we talk about that all
the time although he's transparent no
you know what's transparent when you sit
down and you tell who's ever listening
or watching it I'm not what I appear to
be and that's the truest form of being a
human being I we are all flawed human
beings when we're just trying to be
better every single day the
understanding of that's the truth right
just because you have a world-renown or
radio show doesn't make you different
because sometimes when I talk to guys
I'm just because you're a great athlete
doesn't make you a great person
you have to really go the extra mile and
build that foundation by doing that in
being vulnerable and transparent I mean
that was an example of what you did it's
an example of what how I've changed my
life over the last you know four and a
half years since I walked out of that
cell it's it's been a hundred and eighty
degree lifestyle change and when you see
it from people who are constantly having
a platform people feel like they can
relate to that well I got medicated I
would drink myself of you know to go to
sleep yeah because I didn't want to wake
up in the morning because I knew I was
gonna be in pain and you were trying to
medicate well you did Medicaid the same
thing you did medicate yourself and then
you know you're you're in a world and
then you realize you're in the world and
you go how did I get here and how do I
get out I obviously didn't have the
depths that you had where you went to
prison and you know you broke into
somebody's house to steal opioids right
I mean I didn't I didn't utilize alcohol
in that way
I found another way which was was
opioids right it was what was that first
how did that feel that first time or did
you the first time I you know was ever
introduced to it was after surgery and
it um see I don't even take them I had
my knee replaced I refuse to do it I
won't do it anymore I was so afraid we
just had this instant I just talked to
you about on Monday I was playing in
Mariano Rivera's golf tournament and
playing great through eight holes and
all sudden I'm just like keel over on
the golf course they put me in an
ambulance and take me to the hospital
here in White Plains New York and what
it turns out is I had a hernia and it it
like literally my like my guts were
coming out and they came in and said hey
can we do something for the pain and I
the biggest the biggest thing for
transparency and vulnerability is when
you look at a doctor and you tell them
doc I'm a drug addict I can't have any
pain medication all right and they are
fully aware they don't hear it that
often but when you're honest with them
and then I got sent home after the day
the CT scan and got sent home was with
ibuprofen and that's that's my lifestyle
now and that's okay because there's a
part of you that goes man this hurts and
it'd be nice to have that feeling again
it's just I know why I use it and I can
tolerate pain right when I was in
college bones had to be coming out of my
body to take me off the football field
right so I can I can deal with pain you
know the reason I would take that is
because I'd want to feel different I
didn't want to feel something like you
talked about I would I don't want to
feel this way so many did you want to
disappear yes okay yeah I wanted I
wanted no one to see me I didn't want to
deal with anybody the isolation is what
I was searching but but I would do every
night I would go downstairs and I drink
by myself no it makes complete sense
right I mean I consider all of it it
doesn't make sense when you look back
upon it you're like what do you do right
now that I live in this world by me I'm
talking about me like I distance myself
up my family wanted to see me after
seven o'clock they came downstairs I
would had opportunities to spend time
with family or go on a date or something
like that and I just I didn't I wanted
this I wanted the distance from it all
yeah and that's why it makes sense to me
having lived it and dealing and having
worked in this field and dealing with it
on a daily basis now let's take a break
we'll come back with Ryan I want to talk
some football with you will continue
with Ryan Leaf will do so after this
here on the Dan Patrick show Ryan Leaf
is staying with this former NFL
quarterback
what is Kyler Murray learning right now
well he's not having to learn too much
because this is this might be the this
is the best thing that could have
happened to him as a rookie quarterback
coming out of college you're gonna step
into something that you've done
the entirety of your pretty much a young
adult life playing quarterback but
they're altering the system now I fell
they taught cliff talks like that
decision similar to Oklahoma of what he
ran there yeah it's similar Tyler yeah
it's similar to what they did at
Oklahoma with Kyler
I think they talk a lot more that like
this isn't gonna look like you're Mike
Leach air raid offense because they were
pupils of his yeah
it's it that's all he knows Kliff
Kingsbury you know that's that's what he
was trained and that's how he's that's
how he taught it in college it's gonna
look very similar so I'm interested to
see how that adaptation looks in the NFL
I'm really AM especially with the Graham
Harrell at USC now - there's gonna be
either gonna be a shift of a hybrid of
what Mike Leach does or it's gonna be
these disciples of Mike Leach flat out
in the NFL with in that way what's your
biggest issue with Kyler Murray um I
would say his height I mean that's I'm
just being but does that matter I think
it matters I've seen you know I think it
matters if you don't got the right
offensive lineman that give you space to
throw or give you passing windows yeah I
think it matters but with what they do
and how they space the football field
it's different in college and how you
your your linemen or space because he
did have windows he did have one of
they're gonna be much much tighter split
but we're seeing Baker Mayfield were
seeing you know obviously Drew Brees and
we thought he was the anomaly Russell
Wilson and we're seeing these undersized
what we consider undersized quarterbacks
but it feels like that ability to extend
a play and be able to use your legs not
necessarily going up the field but
extending the play you know to the right
or left is that the future the support
at that position I think so I think the
reason we're seeing such so much more
success is because of their ability to
make plays outside the pocket even Jared
Goff Sabol to do a version of that buy
play action and and really setting his
feet and throwing it's all about what
you're able to do when you set your feet
to throw regardless of where you're at
on the football field well you're moving
in the pocket or you're outside but the
guys that are still winning
championships right now right uh guys
that are pretty much set in that pocket
move kind of within it but I don't know
if I put Baker Mayfield with
Bella check if I put Brady on the Browns
in Baker Mayfield with the Patriots how
big a difference does that make if I
with Baker with the Patriots but they
still be the favored to win the
Superbowl no with the Browns be viewed
as a absolute playoff - yes they would
this is this is Tom Brady we're talking
about right I've said this before I
think if tonda Browns be better than the
Patriots if you switch those two
quarterbacks maybe I don't want to take
away two if I switch coaches and
quarterbacks Cleveland would be playing
in the Super Bowl right I mean this they
you don't have to define like if one had
the other they wouldn't be any good this
what they were able to accomplish as a
team the New England Patriots Tom Brady
and Bill Belichick I've said this before
if Tom Brady gets drafted in the sixth
round by somebody else Tom I don't I
don't and this is not a knock on Tom
Brady at all but I just don't think Tom
Brady's is Tom Brady they they
complement each other in a way but
desserted you had more you had more
ability than Tom Brady well I think a
lot of people did yeah but like there's
something about that position there's
intangibles there's nuance to it it's
not just he can throw it he's got a gun
he's you know he's unbelievable and you
know it Aaron Rodgers might be the
greatest talent yeah I want that quarter
play there michael vick or randall
cunningham but that doesn't always
translate into ultimate success no it
doesn't it's about what you do from
Sunday to Sunday it really is and now
we're seeing how it's done through the
nutrition side of things the training
the studying I just that's the best
piece of advice I can give to a rookie
quarterback when they walk in being a
top pick you find a guy in that locker
room that's played 10 years you ask him
how he's done it and then you follow his
advice verbatim and butkin Daniel Jones
do that with Eli Manning with the Giants
maybe he goes to somebody else in the
locker room maybe he goes to it
offensive lineman who's played 10 years
it doesn't matter all ok so not the
position no it doesn't have to be the
position right I should have went to jr.
sale and I should have went to Rodney
Harrison and I should have said how did
how have you done this how have you
become the proles
that you are and then follow their
advice verbatim I think following
Rodney's more than juniors
his junior was just an unbelievable
talent who freelanced out there and like
he was different I know he but his work
at the stuff outside everything right
how he how he prep prep for the week the
workouts in the morning the nutrition
yeah you have to become this if you're
the quarterback Kyler Murray you're the
CEO of a fortune 500 company right when
you walk in yeah
so you change everything right you get
people you surround people in that
instance it's about nutrition it's about
health it's all these things so you cuz
this may only last five ten years right
we think it's gonna last forever I for
whatever reason in my mind I just
thought I'd probably play football
forever your your last touchdown you
threw 14 touchdowns in the NFL you
remember the last one
Atlanta wait it's your last touchdown
pass I know I didn't think was gonna be
my last right but it was I'll tell you
my first attune I don't know what my
last one was it was with Dallas and I
either it was either against Atlanta I
think was against Atlanta okay so but my
first one was against Buffalo the four
quarterbacks I'd be I only won four
games I only want for my entire career
only four but I beat Steve McNair I beat
Rodney Peete
I beat Warren Moon and I beat a combo of
Doug Flutie and Rob Johnson okay those
were mine those were my victory did you
single-handedly beat them well we sure
charger we sure sure we sure act like it
as we don't ask we don't ask what the
starting left tackles on record is right
I know who's the best player you ever
defensive player you ever played again
um continuously over a career plus
coming cuz I went right from college to
the pros
Darrell Russell he was the Raiders he
was at a USC whence the Raiders and then
tragically passed away in a car accident
yeah really really young he hounded me
at Washington State he hounded me at
Washington State and then when I get to
the NFL there he has two times a year
again in Oakland you know it's just 330
pounds he was like Warren Sapp fast
Aaron Donald fast at like six foot four
just got to you and God
to you and got to probably the best and
then and be the best defensive player I
ever got to hang around and be a part of
was junior junior sail are we ready for
more football games in the regular
season in the NFL I mean as a as a
player I'm not and you want to remove
some preseason games like I could go
with that maybe knock it down to two
preseason if I give you money two more
games two more game checks yeah I'm down
I'm okay with that even though it's not
good for longevity
this isn't listen to this okay we're
football players that's what we do if
you told us the the consequence is that
we're gonna happen down the road that's
always the biggest thing for me within
the NFL and whether people talk to
whether they knew about the concussions
and all the problems I got they knew
about it and didn't say anything that's
where I have a problem I'm not naive
enough to think that when I got into
this game that it wasn't a violent game
and there was gonna be consequences to
it I maybe didn't know the dire
nostalgia
when I was coming out I'd like are you
kidding me that's awesome I gotta play
18 professional football games once you
start losing that innocence and kind of
the kid version of it it I think it
loses this appeal for a player once you
once you start to make grown-up
decisions and you're going wait a minute
well you have a family yes I mean when I
was 21 I was the starting quarterback
trying to lead men who had families to
feed and were 31 years old and going
home to the families after I didn't
understand what that was like hey guys
you want to go drink your paintball and
you know and what people we all went as
a team one summer - waterboy Adam
Sandler's movie I knew he was here the
other day that's what I mean I was 22
years old you know on these guys were
like hey Ryan we can't we gotta we gotta
go home to our families like what is
that he what does that mean I don't know
what that I I want to do this I'm gonna
play golf I want to go drink beers I
want to I want to hang out the boys but
that that's not what the NFL is like
well it's always great to see you you
too
where you off to next um I'm back to LA
my kiddos 20 months old now and MacGyver
yeah what was the other name that if it
wasn't MacGyver it was that was it
if it was a girl I can't say it oh
because Ana would kill me because she's
worried that if I say it someone's gonna
steal it I'm a guy that but we did have
a we did have a girls in the Guyver now
they're doing great
he better be able to get out of trouble
it's the coolest thing I'll ever do
speed that oh nothing better yeah thank
you buddy
oh he's great to see you always great to
see you he's Ryan leaves the former NFL
quarterback transcend recovery
ambassador chairman of focused intensity
Foundation as well and so much more than
that they wish him the best in the
future and hopefully some great things
coming up here shortly for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]